tehát az első reakcióm az volt hogy
hallottam ilyen szirénázásokat meg meg
mivel rég nem hallottam előtte ilyen
szirénát izraelben ez így úgy el voltam
szokva tőle tehát hogy mikor kijöttem
azóta nem nem emlékszem semmilyen
rakétállásra a közelembe és
akkor nyilván tudtam a procedúrát hogy
mit kell csinálni tehát van egy ilyen
páncélé az ablakon hogy be kellett
húzzak azt érdemes tudni hogy izraelben
az újépítésű épületeket úgy építi hogy
van egy ilyen biztonsági szoba
amelyiknek amelyiknek vastagabb a fala
van egy keményebb ajtó és van egy
páncélvédő az ablak kőt amit amit el
szoktunk húzni tehát hogy és van egy
olyan 60 másodpercünk hogy bemenjünk a
biztonsági szobába attól függen hogy hol
érünk tehát hogyha valaki közelebbér
gázálz akkor lehet hogy még kevesebb ha
távolabb akkor lehet hogy tő mintot van
mikor volt az utolsó amikor így ebbe a
biztonságos zónába kellett menek
küljetek a háború előtt nekem nem volt
ilyen tehát turistaként voltam it volt
volt hogy valami rakétázás volt de nem a
közelemben volt tehát nekem nem volt íg
hogy be kell meneküljek de tudtam a
procedúrát